you entered into a film that's so much
about the moment but a screenplay that's
been in process for a long time you had
a great story to tell an important one
to tell but you also to make sure it
didn't slip into documentary yes guy
hibbett had had started developing the
right a wonderful writer guy hibbett
started developing this project 80 years
ago and and in at that point he was sort
of looking into the drones were just
becoming sort of common knowledge if
they were even then and and then nothing
happened with it for I think various
people tried to get it made for five
years I only got the script three years
ago but you're absolutely right when I
got the script the question for me when
I read it was while this is really tense
how accurate is it I knew as much as
most people do then about did then about
drones and I felt that I needed to do a
lot of research so I dived into the
research in terms of both the technology
and where it's going and in terms of the
legal and political arguments and I was
hooked because I think it really does
tap into the discussions that we are
having in the tensions that we're
feeling what we didn't know is where
we'd be three years down the line so I
don't know how comfortable I feel about
where we are now I was afraid the film
would maybe seem too futuristic the
truth is the little beetles and things
that you see in the film are about to be
outdated the next step where these
little beetles are going is to weaponize
them and that would end our movie you
fly the little beetle off the thing and
blow it up next to the guy's head and
you put face recognition software into
the little stereoscopic cameras which
already exist and you select who you
want in the audience to be targeted it
finds you and blows the land Thrax up
your nose so there's a whole level of
creepiness and strangeness that that you
can look up and find out and people like
Stephen Hawking is you imagining when we
were backstage are concerned about in
terms of killer robots and autonomous
drones that take this technology to a
whole new level what was the balance
then I had to be struck between the the
moral arguments that are put forward the
constant
shifting back and forth and the
filmmaking values you had to make a good
film yes um well that that I hope is is
is is the beauty of both guys script and
i hope the film we've made is that for
me when i was reading it I thought this
is a great thriller I want to know
what's going to happen next I'm on the
edge of my seat what is going to happen
next but at the same time I I hope it
leaves folks with a great deal to talk
about I hope it's a an intense film
experience that gets your heart pumping
but I hope that it also leaves you with
many questions and things to talk about
and do some research on and yet it
couldn't be preachy no that's a good
point one of the things I I also didn't
want to do and I hope we haven't done is
tell the audience what to think in a
sense this is a kind of a thought
experiment about what would you do you
guys are the jury I was and still feel
like a jury member and as the facts
unfold and shift your point of view can
shift back and forth mine certainly did
and still does so I think I hope that
the strength of guys script and I hope
we've delivered it in the film is that
it doesn't give you an easy answer and I
don't think these situations are easy i
mean if you change the facts just
slightly you might have a different
point of view what if the number of
people that might be killed is 25 and
the my number of innocent people it
might be killed if you use the health
eyes 10 what if it's 12 a 800 what if
you're in a different neighborhood and
the blowback is worse I think the point
is that not to think that there are some
easy glib answer but to come at this
thing from a a perhaps more humble point
of view but but at the end of the day I
also hope that it humanizes the
situation especially from the point of
view of the the innocent bystanders
whose lives are taken when things go
wrong I think the term collateral damage
dates to the Vietnam War and the
Pentagon but in this it's used very
specifically but you can also see that
the that every person involved in this
every person you see on screen every
character is in a way a victim of
collateral damage yeah I think that's
for
well but I like to think that you can
kind of pause this film that almost any
moment and spin off into a certain
conversation for example you could pause
it on the drone pilots and talk about
the psychological collateral damage
that's happening with these folks you
can obviously talk about the collateral
damage to innocent bystanders and what
the effect of that collateral damage is
on the population around them and
whether we are winning them over to our
cause or alienating them you can pause
on that strange moment of the
politicians who I like the moment where
Monica Dolan's character the Under
Secretary of State for Africa says we
thought she's the maternal almost
stereotypical maternal person and she
suddenly says I actually think we need
to let this happen so that the
population turns against al-shabaab and
not against us you could pause then we
could have a whole conversation about
the extent to which strikes do or do not
help us in the greater objective of
defeating extremist ideology with a lot
of feature films the actors can probably
leave the character like leaving a suit
of clothes in a closet but how did the
nature of this subject that's so near
the knuckle for what's going on nowadays
how did it affect the shoot the cast and
the crew as you were doing it um well
just as an example I I remember there
was a moment with Helen Mirren um we
built her banker in an old warehouse we
didn't the studios were being used
they're beautiful studios in Cape Town
for magnificent studios which Michael
Bay has for a show called black sails
full app so we couldn't use the
beautiful studio so we built in
warehouses and I'm thrilled that
Michaels show is out there employing
lots of people but we built in this
really not very attractive warehouse and
then we built this bunker in there and I
remember Helen coming off after about
day three and going Gavin I can't
imagine what it's like to do this every
single day to come to work as the person
we based her character on does and do
this job every single day she was a
little shaken after 12 hours of shooting
inside this bunker you shot in South
Africa before
which won an academy award for best
foreign language film thank you and you
shot this film there but you also had a
Somali cast don't tell us about how that
came to pass well logistically it proved
to be too tricky to try and do this in
Kenya for many reasons Kenya's a great
country in security foremost among
curity exactly and so we went to Cape
Town where there is a tremendous filmic
infrastructure great cruise many of whom
I've worked with before and there
happens to be a very very large Somali
refugee community in cape town that is
whole neighborhoods of their own people
who have fled al-shabaab and so every
actor and indeed every extra you see in
the film is a Somali refugee every
Somali actor so admin hajiya who plays
the young girl's father fled because his
brother was shot by al-shabaab frankly
and and when you talk to these folks we
went into I have an amazing South
African casting director moon in li and
when we went into these Somali
communities and had open castings some
people came in and heard what the gist
of the story was and heard that
al-shabaab was in some way involved in
the story turn in you know what I mean
as characters in the film and walked
right out just out of fear so the folks
who stay have amazing stories that
little girl is a refugee her mother and
her little bro little real-life little
brothers the little boy who runs to her
at the end and for the bread that's her
a real brother and her mum and her other
sister are just two of the characters
that come to buy bread from her at one
point and they have escaped across five
countries to get to Cape Town I'm so
amazing amazing people it makes you very
humble when you're working with the very
often at the end of films that deal with
military subjects you say we want to
thank the United States Navy for its
cooperation I didn't see anything like
that here so has the NSA come knocking
on your door yet probably I will say
this they'd never let you know no that's
you great question um we did not
approach the
ntaganda film office or the Air Force
film officers and they exist and and not
because we don't want to we just felt
that this film needed to be made without
the endorsement of anyone you also don't
see the endorsement of Amnesty
International or reprieve all of whom we
consulted we consulted with different
organizations we consulted with people
in the military and one and I did
extensive research of people in military
many of the lines that you see in the
film come directly from the mouths of
people in military i'll give you one
great example when aaron paul says i am
the pilot-in-command responsible for
releasing the weapon I i need the
collateral i will not i need you to run
the collateral damage estimate again i
will not release my weapon until that
happens that is a direct line from the
colonel who trained the girl islets who
by the way emailed me and congratulating
me on the film the other day i think he
was very nervous and didn't want to be
named some of their names are in the
special thanks without rank but others
are not and and the reason for that is
that there is a kind of last line of
defense that a drone pilot has and we
did have military advisors on the set
the pilot that that was on the set
advise erin was a f-16 pilot for 10
years he flew in the iraq war and he has
been flying drones for six years and now
is in the reserve so he still flies but
he consults on movies and he flies um
drones civilian drones for movies with
cameras so he was a great guy and that
was useful because for the actors you
want them to feel that they know that
when they push this button or move the
sleeve or touch that autopilot or read
the dash 34 checklist that they are
absolutely doing the right thing today
as the ghost of Nuremberg haunts this
film yes but you want them to know just
as actors that they're doing the right
thing so that they can get the technical
stuff out of the way and get back to
acting but to your point of that goes to
Nuremberg yes thank you for raising that
the question for an aaron paul and it
happened to our advisor which is where
we got the line
is as a young officer in the military
you do not promise to obey all orders
you swear to obey all legal orders and
this is fundamental because if you obey
an illegal order as you point out you
can be charged with a warm crime if that
were not the case they could be no
Nuremberg so the pressure on a 24 25
year old pilot if he thinks that this is
an illegal order for any reason he is
actually obliged to say so now many of
us will say I bet they hardly ever do
and I bet we'd be right but they can and
part of what I got from the colonel who
trained the pilots was an immense
frustration at the point that he was
working bear in mind this was already
years ago when we were doing the
research because the CIA was using air
force pilots in some of their operations
and those Air Force pilots their names
are known their ranks are known they
can't hide behind this anonymous they're
not anonymity so if a drone strike turns
out to have been illegally in any way
who's on the hook so it was amazing to
me to find that within the military
itself there was a great deal of dispute
some people are incredibly Pro these
drones some people in the military
described them as humana humane as
weapons and we can talk about that if
you like but and others are this is
really a tactical weapon and we should
not confuse it with a strategy and
whether we're using them strategically
correctly or not is a huge debate in
terms of the blowback question won't you
please thank Gavin hood thank you so
much for coming folks really appreciate
it thank you